welcome to CBS this morning we begin of
course with major political developments
on both sides of the country in
Washington the impeachment of President
Trump is on hold as you may have heard
his Republicans and Democrats square off
over whether a fair trial for mr. Trump
is even possible in the Republican held
Senate and at the 6th Democratic
presidential debate in Los Angeles
Democrats turn their fire on each other
with the biggest attacks reserved for
the surging mayor of South Bend Indiana
Pete Budaj edge it was the latest in a
series of clashes on the role of money
in the campaign just over six weeks
before the first votes are cast in Iowa
ed O'Keefe is in Los Angeles for us ed
good morning why was this debate so
heated
well Tony let's put it this way Los
Angeles is a town that's produced its
fair share of TV dramas and it was a bit
dramatic for sure on the debate stage
last night that's because well there's
unanimous agreement that the president
should be impeached and that the trial
should proceed as scheduled they had
this was the night the gloves finally
came off they finally started throwing
punches and most of them went at young
mayor Pete Budaj because he's rising in
the polls billionaires should not pick
the next president of the United States
senator Elizabeth Warren challenged
mayor Pete Buda judge for recently
holding an exclusive fundraiser in a
wine cave in California's Napa Valley
Buddha judge pushed back this is the
problem with issuing purity tests you
cannot yourself pass senator your net
worth is 100 times mine eventually
senator Amy Klobuchar tried to stop the
bickering I came here to make a case for
progress and I have never even been to a
wine cave but she took her own shot to
do the judge over his previous comments
about his Washington outsider status you
basically mocked the hundred years of
experience on the stage and I have not
denigrated your experience as a local
official I have been one you know I just
think you should respect our experience
she want to talk about the capacity to
win try putting together a coalition to
bring you back to
with 80% of the vote as a gay dude in
Mike Pence's Indiana that would be one
thing there were also questions of age
and gender senator Warren you would be
the oldest president ever inaugurated
I'd like you to weigh in as well I'd
also be the youngest woman ever
inaugurated and there was an
acknowledgement of the lack of diversity
it's both an honor and disappointment to
be the lone candidate of color on the
stage tonight
I miss Kemal I miss Cory though I think
Cory will be back a result in part
because of fundraising thresholds you
know what you need to donate to
political campaigns disposable income
throughout the night the contenders face
questions about the economy we need an
economy that focuses on the needs of a
press exploited people climate change
I'm the only one on this stage you said
climate is my number one priority health
care Joe's plan essentially we retain
the status quo that's not true thank you
and how they'd fix a broken Washington
former Vice President Joe Biden made an
especially personal plea if anyone has
reason to be angry with the Republicans
and not want to cooperate it's me the
way they've attacked me and my son to my
family we have to be able to get things
done now we mentioned that impeachment
also came up and the candidates all
agreed that the president should allow
his top aides to testify at the upcoming
trial but it was Andrew yang who said
that this party should quote stop being
obsessed over impeachment and that it
needs to focus instead on winning back
voters who had supported President Trump
in 2016 all right ed thank you
you